This is not juggling.
This is called misdirection.
And no matter what
level you are magic,
we've got stuff here for you.
Learning basic
principles of magic,
it's like learning
chords on a guitar.
Once you know a few
simple principles,
you can build your
whole magic routine.
But if you're smart
enough to work silently,
it brings out a huge
amount of wonder.
When you don't
talk, the audience
has to tell itself
the story, and they
don't know where it's going.
The basic method behind this
uses sound misdirection.
[COINS JINGLING]
[COUGH]
Palming is when you hide
something in your hand.
You're going to bring
your whole hand around
to conceal that ball and
completely close your fist.
That will make all
your relatives laugh.
The simplest trick you
can do involves exploring
how do we know what is true.
Take those two
ends and tie them
in a double knot
around each other.
Yeah, I'll see you later.
[LAUGHTER]
There's more magic in
cards than anything else.
You don't need to know the card.
You just need to know the
card next to the card.
Was that your card?
Whoa
Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
If you get good at magic, you
will automatically get good
at a certain kind of acting.
Magic forces you to learn
about storytelling, assumptions
about the way we
perceive the world.
And then smash it.
That's it.
You must be empathetic.
You must try to see yourself
through another person's eyes,
and I think you
have to simply say
that one of the things that
makes life worth living
is giving other people joy.
We're Penn and Teller, and
this is our MasterClass.